c'est quoi c'est une expérience qu'elle
voulait qu'on la met en arrêt on
n'arrive pas à la rame et fait combien
de temps j'en sais rien deux ou trois
mini moi je suis enchantée palette non
attends repos ça remplace sofia au
massage cardiaque
sofia mais lui la couverture
réfrigérante aller en hyperthermie
ensuite charge de défibrillateurs à 360
est maintenant prête dès qu'on a
récupéré une activité cardiaque même
irrégulière tu lui mets les palettes et
envoie le jura puissance max aller boxer
ce qui est en train de nous arriver ses
apparitions ces hallucinations
ça ne va aller qu'en empirant si on
n'arrive pas à comprendre si on ne
trouve pas si on ne trouve pas une
solution a choisi la cuy nous tuera tous
[Musique]
tu la ramènes on dégage tu as vu une
lumière blanche ça ressemblait plus de
l'énergie pure son cerveau a été
reprogrammé je veux être le prochain
on dégage je vais guérir tous ceux qui
passent entre mes mains aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]
je cherchais pas à faire avancer la
science
[Musique]